[Music]
first drafts of the movie go show the
world that's the second draft
oh yeah the second draft about to read
it today oh [ __ ] today's a table real
where we doing that we don't hear the
old you want a new office man I'm gonna
be Skyped in though cuz I gotta pick up
Isaac oh you like in the car yeah well
you're like all the rumblings of your
car around dude that'll be great we
should give you stage directions stage
directions is when you have to read all
the every single line like the narration
yeah yeah interior enter right stage
hopefully everyone's in the movie and so
in some degree Dhabi time that'd be
awesome
hell no y'all can't act I want to hear
yours no good Instagram post about the
[ __ ] the movie I was crying that's
the best Photoshop I've ever seen in my
life
thank you Nikki took my phone she posted
that I didn't even know yeah your post
was all sentimental and hers was just
like some [ __ ] or whatever I don't
know what it wasn't cute for a woman no
yeah yeah yeah I loved her more for sure
yeah we all get why yeah I mean she's
like wait wait huh wait huh it's been in
your wallet living forever
yeah yeah yeah I just have to take it
out yeah well cuz I noticed it was
giving me like pretty damaged like in
there like it's pretty faded already if
you really loved her you would have
laminated it a long time ago angers no I
but yeah I know I had to put it in like
a like a better spot cuz it that's
[ __ ] cute rubbing against my ass all
day and [ __ ] like that's cute well thank
them don't try to make a comment just to
fill it in so I can't I had a ticket
stub of from our first date in my wallet
like the whole time that's a big deal
over years don't water it down you saved
it yeah yeah yeah you know what I did
what you did with your Instagram that
you just secured your next marriage if
this doesn't work out how so by putting
that sweet a [ __ ] out there all the
girls like all my [ __ ] god I want to
[ __ ] Steve but he's married so you
already secured the
one with your post I've seen some
comments about you see like I mean
that's how you got Nikki or everyone
pieces oh yeah you were so sweet with
their ex that Nikki saw you saw how you
treated your ex and she was like I gotta
have this dude that's true girls are
watching I gotta come the next girl oh
[Laughter]
my god it's like he got married he's
been with her for five years all for the
long ball yeah what would that be I'd be
a [ __ ] psychopath no well you guys
had a really fun Valentine's Day yeah we
went to Vegas and we went alone which is
something that we don't normally do
because we're always like we're like
let's go with the crew let's do this so
we're like [ __ ] that we have a kid now
like we gotta remember who we are as a
couple so we like we're all romantic it
cute and then you get there and you're
you're in the hotel room and you hear
the gentle blow of the air conditioner
as you don't really say anything
and then you're like I wish we brought
the firm usually it's like that but this
one was really good you really oughta
turn ourselves and we needed it
so we talked a lot for a very weird wow
we just talked you just pop in the hotel
room yeah right completely naked that's
always cool dude cuz you just you know
when you're doing that like the
post-coital spoons like talking [ __ ] if
we Topher grab a boob and it's like it's
like you get full full board yeah just
real quick like man you know what's dope
though so we stand at the Aria just like
a regular room and even their regular
rooms they got this iPad theme and I was
tripping the [ __ ] out the whole time
because now you can just stay in yours
you guys watch the Tom Segura
on Netflix it's time about how lazy
people are we can order everything from
your bed now and then that just
reinforce what he was saying because in
this iPad you can close the drapes
change the AC turn on music turn on TV
even on room service you can go per dish
filet mignon will take 70 minutes a bowl
of fruit will take 20 minutes what it's
done of calling like hey can I get the
bacon cheeseburger and they like all
hold on a sec you know all right
oh well the chef has said is gonna take
an hour you already know everything and
you just press all these buttons Oh
massages everybody this is a brand do
you know do I use the Barneses
never make me want to leave the hotel
room so we usually do gamble but then
this song went just to like bond and
then we've got we did get a massage and
then watch Bruno Mars which is dope he's
super sick performer like always I've
seen those since like the beginning and
these things better than the tracks that
was awesome so knowing you though when
you go to bond right you're like okay so
from 9:30 to 11:30 we're bonding we're
going to the casino floor we'll have
dinner yeah we can bond over dinner but
first I can't get into the conversation
he wasn't like that anymore there was no
agenda like there was none of that we
loved it about you it it's just too
logical funny man he's like oh wait
honey don't you know I know you want to
talk about this but we're done with
bonding now it's all logic
I know I change this trip so you're
exact on a roll throwing people under
the [ __ ] Dutchess wheel that's his
job 18-wheeler you know you're a [ __ ]
romantic as [ __ ] what you guys do
guys nothing really honestly we just got
or okay in the morning I did wake up to
roses and box of Casey just murdered a
family of roses and literally scalped
the petals off of their head warrior put
all over the bed
yep shipped in from Italy and you're
like no nobody knew no it was really
romantic it was you're right and then we
had like DiGiorno for dinner that's a
brand deal we were there yeah no but
then we also had we had it for
Valentine's Day dinner it was really
nice by the way though even though it's
a brand deal and I know it
that [ __ ] you bought [ __ ] DiGiorno was
off the [ __ ] chain are we in the
brand deal am I the only guys not in the
brand building a new brand new I'm
getting paid pepperoni you could invite
me just for the pepperoni I don't give a
[ __ ] that's good well you guys will be
getting invited again just enjoy the
video it's good Valentine's Day we had
this one is my favor and him oh man did
you make it yeah and you didn't want to
go anywhere else only she is on it man
what a good brain girl that's really
good this is who you want for your
product
she won't throw your product I was
posting a story about it and then so the
first story clip was me saying like I
got something cooking in the oven and I
got so many DM saying like oh my god
people think you're pregnant but I'm I
really do it out that I'm pregnant it's
not gonna be exciting anymore they've
been guessing because you wear oversized
sweater so they're like she's definitely
hiding that she has a kid now they're
gonna just say it's the giorno now
you're like we have a surprise that
night messages on our way
no did you guys see Frankie's performing
all that was I [ __ ] had a Valentine's
Day don't move on hold on hold on I did
you interrupted you described it
no nobody so excited got a tow you got a
tow the world show you're the one that
had such a glad you know what you're
never romantic so I want to hear you
describe your thoughts on the room I
want to hear how how much fun you had
because you were smiling the whole damn
entire day I'm with Jess I want to hear
your romance
I want to hear just this side of this
noon I want to hear what he thought and
I want to hear what she thought because
the cameras on right now she wants to
act like a little badass but all of
these hear what you said first oh yeah
okay I like that I'm with you John she's
always got this guard up like she's
pretending to be like all like tough and
[ __ ] but in real life if so if you try
to talk about their love stuff it just
gets sad in here right we're just gonna
continue usually want to admit that she
had a blast so I went to the gym I got
up and I went to barbell and then when I
got back there was there was a brandy Oh
what barbell brigade thank you thank you
so there's this little like Square vase
with like roses and all that stuff and
then there's a little barbell no no we
should got home from the gym they're
like got a heart with a little smiley
face on it on the card and then inside
was those little love massage for 15
minutes it does happen it's like you can
suck my dick whenever you want
there's only with this coupon yes 50
coupons you can [ __ ] it rub my balls
lick my butt you can eat my butt not
lick my butt it what is saying the
letter it said I can use it anytime
because it's long overdue I am romantic
yes give me credit goddamn she's so
proud I kind of like forced him to do
what I wanted so like we went to the
restaurant that I wanted to eat at and
then he didn't want to get ice cream but
then we can't walk it ice all the way
three blocks to get ice cream which
restaurant you guys go to shabu shabu
house but we had to wait like an hour
it's the one in the middle of the plaza
you know that's the original shabu
restaurant and all of America tell me
about it I'm gonna bring video and I'm
the one getting dick I like that place
they cut the meat leave it until it's
room temperature before they bring you
in I love the chairs man a great seating
proud of you show me show me show me
what happened under that JQ news pounded
the booty was a day or two before that
it was a couple of days before that it
was pre Valentine thought was Valentine
yeah oh yeah oh yeah that was the time
were you like oh you suck my dick but it
wasn't good enough this time
yep oh yeah as I said it's always magic
always great check it in I'm a real Yelp
reviewer you know what that means if
your dick sucking is not good that means
that she's bored she's bored yes it's
her fault you could count on me for real
real reviews but see if she's bored
that's why was she sucking your dick you
hold our iPad did the video stop I'm
sucking altered carbon while doing
kind of like ya hot asian guys in there
there is yeah
and that white guy what's his name he's
pretty hot so we try to watch the day of
it but you said it felt too dark oh
there's a ton of shirtless men in that
show that's great well anyway back to
Fergie though oh yeah Fergie performance
it was really bad
is the funniest thing on earth I'll show
you guys so if you didn't see it did you
I saw it on Instagram it was going on
she tried like a jazzy rendition of it
[Music]
it's that again yes you know that cut
and cardi B which is like hello I'm sure
it's more like a different time yeah
yeah that's all fine they took the clip
of the worst part on Instagram all the
players started you already know what
they're laughing at so then the other
dude looks at him like oh [ __ ]
like you know it does feel like the SNL
performance when they're trying to make
fun of another senior
inside wandering around
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is that Jimmy Kimmel she's feeling it
right now she has no idea she knows now
now they're all laughing oh no what
they're trying not to didn't work out
that's actually what she said she was
like you know what I tried my best
she's a good singer I don't know how she
what does she do well she was trying to
get people to kneel for the anthem oh I
think that's sexualized of the thing too
yeah she was gonna start [ __ ] sucking
off the microphone it sounded like what
something that plays well like a hand
touches a glass wall on a shower yeah
like a steamy glass yeah yeah yeah I
thought I saw one we were it was like a
photo of like a janitors ring of keys
and it's kinda like freaky pick one Oh
Marius is it possible to find a Phrygian
cardi B one it's not easy to find for ye
cardi B we got two cardi B oh my god
it's like we're all gonna party right
now it's like oh now played this video
yeah yeah I watched a Chris D'Elia had a
like a he put a little tiny video like
response to this and he was like you
guys hired Fergie for this she has a
song called let's get [ __ ] in here
so why would you expect her to like do
this professionally and perfectly like
she was gonna be weird about it she's in
black eyed peas like it's Fergie well I
mean I think it was great I mean I like
that they tried to be creative with it
but I think the star bangle the star
bingo
the star-spangled banner it is such a
traditional song that I feel like
artists do get tired of it so they want
different renditions but it's one of
those songs that you just can't do they
nobody can touch the anthem after
Whitney man
when Whitney did the anthem at the Super
Bowl that even Beyonce honestly no I
don't think Beyonce's a know you you
watch this video on YouTube of Whitney
Houston Jeff Linda when she did the
Super Bowl like national anthem that
[ __ ] was knots man
I found the cardi video is it 56k
loading I love parties
what is she listening to I don't think
it's the same event at the same time the
lighting looks differ
just dancing or some [ __ ] I gotta say
this is one of those things though were
you here
social media blowing up and it's like is
the worst [ __ ] of all human time and
space and then I'm I'm like oh cool like
I go to watch it and I'm like oh it's
not it's not as exaggerated as people
made it up yeah like I want I was
expecting her to be [ __ ] farting or
something hard swear it was like ooh but
the rest of it was like okay cause if
this was at a YouTube show it'd be like
a standing ovation 100% but all hell
yeah this YouTube Raquel that nice cover
there's worse ones too if you go down
the list of [ __ ] up national yeah oh
yeah there's like Roseanne Barr one from
like this actually have that one oh God
Roseanne Barr yeah like a long time ago
but she's a comedian like in character
yes she knows what she's doing dude she
knows what she's doing
[Laughter]
she knew what she her [ __ ] board her
it's good like media attention though
she hasn't even been like in the media
and so long Roseann was [ __ ] around
but do you think people were booing her
because it was bad or because they knew
she was looking around I think they
thought that she thought it was good
really I hope so maybe they are booing
for the disrespect there's that too it
kind of reminds me of like how Mariah
Carey totally messed up the New Year's
thing last year but then she came back
again this year and she did better so
it's kind of like she's more in the
spotlight like if you mess up something
and the media covers it and like you get
more attention she'll probably do this
again somewhere else and kill it and
then it'll be good to mess up sometimes
it might be a calculated PR or something
yeah I think Oh J miscalculated his mas
a little bit a little the couple times
two because he had six and then he
jacked his own shed there just a couple
changes he fit amazing
[Music]
Oh